Doctor Strange I always suspected this  day would come because you always  suspected this day would come I'm ready  on May 6th  nothing can prepare you  for the Mind vending  descent into madness this is the only  way  doctors drink the Multiverse of Madness  3dpg-13 a seat in premium Arch formats  in IMAX  this universe is only one of an infinite  number  [Music]  vast Multiverse  Stephen Strange your Reckoning is long  overdue  [Music]  holding Peter's May 6th tickets on sale  now  the Multiverse  just life or death  could use an Avenger  there are other Avengers we'll get you  back on The Lunchbox  fate of the Multiverse depends on us  no pressure man  Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of  Madness